so we we talked about this in the in the
lobby about finding Jesus right
okay let's talk about that what is it
with women when they when they I don't
say hit the wall but they they get to
30. then they get 35 and then they
between 35 and 45 or 40 go find Jesus
yeah and then what happens then talk
about that because you see these
responses oh God I am the Jesus I'd like
to say I'm Catholic I know I know you
guys are talking about Catholic schools
we're talking about Catholic girls yeah
yeah I am I am Catholic so I I don't
want it to come off like I think
religion's a bad thing or like any of
that because a lot of times people
misconstrue what I'm saying but I just
think there's a lot of like feminism has
infiltrated the church and they
constantly Pander to women and tell us
what we want to hear and they basically
tell us that you can be like 30 31 32 33
with a child and do this born-again
virgin type stuff and the girls buy it
they buy it and they buy it they think
there's a man at the end of it that's
equally yoked no man that says like
super religious it's trying to wife up a
32 year old with a kid I'm sorry but do
you think that the men that buy into
that the The Simpsons at the church buy
into that will do that
because because they're the ones that
are part of that you know born again
virgin right yeah so they accept that
but outside of the church you're like no
I'm good well I think that's why you see
like men are leaving the church
really if you look at the under 40 stats
I don't know what they are off the top
of my head but men are leaving the
church going to going to a church look
at the people under like 38 roughly
they're mostly women and I don't want to
say something because I was thinking
about this on the way here
um you know I'm a Christian right but
I'm not a bible thumper right yeah and
when people say oh you guys are
hypocrites no I'm a hypocrite
Christianity is not a hypocrite
Catholicism is a part of Christianity
that's not a hypocrite or Islam or
whatever religion but it's the person
right because I sin every day as a man
not not sexually I'm just talking like I
speed that's a sin or I may look at a
woman else she's hot right check out a
woman she's hot you know and I had this
lady say oh why do you look at women or
or you know like women's pages I said
well it's okay for somebody to like my
girlfriend's Instagram but then I can't
like somebody's you see what I mean it's
a it's a it's a hypocritical move well
and they all talk about like the men
always preach about like issues from the
women's point of view
like they never and you'll once you see
this oh God I watched Rolo stream on
Church like a couple years ago and I
titled it Rollo ruined church for me not
because because like all of the freaking
um churches they always preach about
problems from the woman's point of view
so for example they'll have um I'm gonna
say corn addiction oh yeah yeah but they
never have social media addiction groups
for the women they never talk about I've
never heard a preacher talk about that
they'll talk about men cannot cheat or
step out but they don't talk about the
women that stop sleeping with their
husbands after they get the two kids
they don't talk about that's a sin right
you're supposed to and the other thing
too I don't know how we got down this
road but but it's funny and and I don't
know these individuals yeah I don't know
Matt Walsh I don't know Ben Shapiro yeah
but you know Patrick Pitt David or
whatever they're more on the
conservative side right you have the red
pill conservative two different things
so I saw somebody talk about that on on
the whatever podcast what's red pill
conservative they're they're separate
they're separate right I'm kind of in
the middle I'm kind of got but it's
funny because
a lot of these guys have slept with
their wife before they were married
which is a sin right so in essence I
think when people say you know I I use
you know like I said I I love Jesus but
I'm not a bible thumper right I'm not
going after people with the Bible I'm
not perfect but I I use it as a
foundation to keep me grounded right
because I'm as a man I'm like hey I'm
I'm ready to go well that's fine I need
some to ground me now I'm not perfect
you know I play poker that's gambling
right that's a sin I'll check out a hot
chick wow she's hot you see the ass
that's a sin but I'm not like the bible
thumper guy that's just how I was raised
a Catholic and I just came in on uh you
know just a Foursquare Christian you
know whatever you know
non-denominational right you know go
ahead well I think it's more honest
because a lot of times I think what
turns people off of Christianity is like
this holier than thou attitude you know
what I mean yeah and so like a lot of
times like I I was I was beefing with
the Christians recently and a blessing
says I should stay away from that I'm
sorry I can't do it but I'm sorry I
didn't
but before we go by the way I'm gonna
give a shout out we're not gonna put
them on camera uh blessings is her
producer right yeah producer and he's a
wizard a genius so if you ever need
questions on any of this stuff like go
watch uh just pearly things podcast the
show is amazing it's produced properly
it's it's one of the best shows out
there so go ahead yeah I don't remember
what I was talking about I was going in
on the older than now oh oh I was
beefing with the Christians on Twitter
because I said okay I said if a guy
steps out you should try to work it out
because I said that you're putting your
kid at every statistical disadvantage
they're more likely to go to prison
they're more likely to commit suicide
they're more likely to run away from
home like if and they're more likely to
be sexually abused by whoever the woman
dates next so it's like okay you're
gonna put your kid at every statistical
Advantage because he he screwed some
stripper in Vegas it's like maybe we
could try to work it out and I started
looking into like the cheating data and
um it was like 15 of only like three
percent of the time
um it was like the guy's a Serial
cheater the majority of the time it's a
one-time thing now let's just say
they're big liars and we double it
that's still only six percent of the
time it seems like it could be worked
out but all the preachers were just like
oh no you can divorce for it and I'm
like we're supposed to be on the same
team we're supposed to be on this thing
yeah like keep the family together like
I thought that but you know maybe and
there's different forms of cheating
right right like these these women will
have these these Instagram now my
girlfriend's Instagram she's she's in
Fitness she competes so there's some
pictures on there but she's she's not
she doesn't have my only fan she's not
showing you know right but she's an
athlete right so she's like well do you
wanna I said no I'm not even on her
Instagram I don't want to be because
that's her brand right I ruined her
brand she put me on her Instagram she
lost like you know 2 2500 followers
immediately right and vice versa I don't
want women feminists going after her
just like your ex right people went
after him right so I don't want to get
into that but uh uh speaking of which
you're single mm-hmm so what is your
ideal man look like ideal guy
um I would say I like guys that are
super conservative
ideally in the U.S because that's kind
of an issue I'm like moving so ideally
he'd be in the U.S
um what kind of money does he need to
make uh maybe like in US Dollars like I
don't know 40 50. 40 50k yeah I mean I
don't I don't know everyone's gonna say
I'm cap it depends what he does
okay well let's start out it is what he
does this isn't we're not trying to
diagnose you and break you down but
you're very successful yeah okay I know
you do more than six figures We're not
gonna talk about it okay uh but you're
how tall are you I'm six foot oh my God
I know and you got heels on I like guys
you know I'm comfortable with my height
I sound like I'm comfortable with my
weight no yeah but you're tall yes yeah
no I was thinking about it I'm like yeah
because on the average as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible